katia c'est le deuxième orale cette
semaine pour le ministre de la justice
son intervention devant les députés
lundi avait déjà suscité quelques
polémiques
oui en effet il avait semblé quelque peu
déstabilisés par le nombre des viols
estimés en france et le nombre de
condamnations donc aujourd'hui il se
livre à l'exercice devant les sénateurs
avec pour le moment un ton un peu plus
bas d'un quart en fait cette commission
manque de temps aujourd'hui eric dupond
moretti ne restera que jusqu à 14h50
donc les échanges sont menées tambour
battant
on vous l'avait dit 7 cette audition qui
est celle de la commission des lois mais
elle est ouverte à toutes les
commissions ce qui fait que de très
nombreux sénateurs pourront poser des
questions et bien elle a été faite à la
demande des sénateurs socialistes et
justement nous avons interrogé jean
pierre sueur à ce sujet je propose de
l'écouter il est pour faire une réforme
très bonne excellente de la justice des
mineurs alors dans ce cas là est ce que
ce serait pas bien de faire un projet de
loi plutôt qu'une ordonnance afin que le
parlement apporte tout son talent et
toutes ses idées sur ce sujet
troisièmement il est pour les cour
d'assises et le jury populaire
mais vous voyez bien que
l'expérimentation à sept départements
des cours criminel départemental étendu
à 20 ou 30 départements a pour objet de
mettre en pièces
ce jury populaire est-ce qu'il va
arrêter d'expérimentation est ce qu'il
en restait à 7
est-ce qu'il va revenir ce qui a été
fait avant voilà des questions
pascal et parole il y a les actes
voilà déjà deux sujets qui seront
abordés lors de cette audition eric
dupond moretti a en préambule expliqué
qu'il y a de la défiance donna de la
part de nos concitoyens vis-à-vis de la
justice et qu'il voulait changer le
regard des français dans le domaine et
là tout d'abord évoqué le cas des femmes
victimes de violence est apparemment une
des priorités de son ministère
il a évoqué la question de la justice de
proximité avec un déplacement du juge
dans les territoires pour les jeux
démineurs aussi un grand accent là
dessus il souhaite que les mineurs
soient jugés très rapidement et non pas
à leur majorité il a évoqué également la
condition pénitentiaire laquelle il
souhaite remédier et un taux de
remplissage des prisons qui dit il était
historiquement bas il veut que ça se
poursuivre de la sorte
voilà ce qu'on peut savoir d'ores et
déjà de cette audition qui est toujours
en cours merci katia technique en direct
donc du sénat à paris